on the floor gabriel
here's lillard now for three and damien
lillard with his first points of the
second half
patience right there the shot blocking
waiting for the shot blocker to fly by
looked at the clock step behind the line
lebron james oh
we hit the air talking about the alpha
dogs with these two teams
they've led most of this game at one
point had a 16 point lead
in the second quarter early mccullum
can't shake caruso fires it anyway
in traffic he buries a three tough shot
six to go
[Applause]
lillard long three is up and then damien
lillard
just massive range that's right dane
times says nurkic
he might be right 28 points now this is
31 now for damon this is why you have to
pick him up early you have to hedge
right side just now getting into the
picture
[Applause]
danny green on mccullum mccullough got
it
boy lillard and mccullum coming alive
here in this fourth quarter
and done for the blazers on the lillard
miss james
caldwell pope and it's closed by
whiteside
and a trip of lillard oh you're watching
this game and you're excited
about the weak side help look how high
it gets because you're supposed to do
that if you're kcp you think wait a
minute i'm wide open but
davis has his man inside so it clogs the
lane
[Applause]
all the way danny we just saw that i
don't know how it happened
james with trent on it turns a corner oh
another block by white side
number five tonight for hassan and it's
because the lakers can't have that much
spacing you know why they don't have
many three-point shooters
like that spacing you know why they
don't have many three-point shooters
like that like that damien
lillard if you don't do that one dribble
don't foul get out the way white side
and let dave
have his time who's my state on that
side to give lebron help
we call that zoning up the weak side
lyrics back on the floor give it to
carmelo anthony for three he's got it
carmelo anthony delivers
in with the foul here i was always
impressed with playing against mello
because you knew he had that bully ball
in the post but one of the things i
don't think we give great players credit
for a couple of big
three-pointers made
danny green trying to answer
follow won't go lebron james with the
follow puts it in
oop and jump shots and he can do that
look at nercus he's been
murking me in lillard with davis autumn
nice pass nurkish got to get one up
and danny green excellent defense by
green and the lakers
lebron up ahead davis taps it to himself
and finishes with two hands
that's the reason why they set the pick
so kuzma would switch out now you got
passes around the perimeter
trent jr for three he's got it the
threes are falling big time here in the
fourth for the blazers
wow what a ball game just when you
thought the blazers
running rough shot with all of that
action nurkic hammers one home
and the blazers throw it into fifth gear
late in the fourth quarter
say why get here if we're not going to
commit we heard dame dollar
say before the playoffs listen i don't
even want to go to the bubble
and risk anything if we aren't allowed a
chance to really get into it
nerk is right there saying trust